mais d'abord le procès papon avec une
audience importante aujourd'hui à la
barre des témoins l'historien michel
bergès qui a passé des années aux côtés
des parties civiles avant de prendre le
parti de maurice papon
aujourd'hui il a présenté de nouveaux
documents à l'audience mais qui
semble-t-il n'ont pas convaincu sur
place philippe denis et puis indique
jusqu'au dernier moment
michel bergès à réviser ces notes comme
s'il voulait soigneusement pesé chacun
de ses mots ce politologue est plongé
depuis 15 ans dans les archives de la
sphère papon longtemps aux côtés des
accusateurs il a ensuite coupé les ponts
pour se rapprocher de l'accusé mais
comme il le dira d'emblée à la barre je
n'ai ni à attaquer ni à défendre un camp
il tiendra cette conduite pendant 2h30
d'un exposé très prudent devant un
accusé attentif michel bergès s'est
contenté de souligner les incertitudes
du dossier et de prodiguer des conseils
à la cour pour parvenir à la vérité
le chercheur a bien fourni quelques
documents qualifiés de pièces nouvelles
par le président mais aucun ne semble
contenir une de ces révélations
annoncées la foule de curieux plus
nombreuses aujourd'hui que d'habitude en
a été pour ses frais c'est un pétard
mouillé
et c'est bien ce que je pensais avant
l'audience
j'en suis
georges les confirmations maintenant
aucun
amener les moments
laisser supposer
l'inscription
a été fait de façon
tronqué ou de façon insultante à michel
bergès samba la queue entre les jambes
sans avoir rien apporté seniors
une
remarque révisionnisme sur la période de
l'occupation ce qui m'attirait ce sont
thomas des révélations c'est l'analyse
c'est la compréhension par un véritable
historien qui connaît ce qui s'est passé
qui connaît le dosier comme personne
c'est une analyse
donc vous avez remarqué que maurice
papon est pratiquement absent bien sûr à
travers ses doutes
michel bergès s'est gardé d'accabler
maurice papon mais il ne l'a pas
franchement défendue non plus le
sauvetage de certains juifs par exemple
que l'accusé revendiquent ils auraient
été faits dans une proportion limitée
c'était du grappillage a même dit le
chercheur son témoignage avait été
annoncé comme un éventuel tournant du
procès il a été presque anodin